non je les ai tués
et je les ai tués aussi je ne comprends pas
comment tu as pu avoir
hmm
c'est possible comment tu fais ça
je ne sais pas
euh tu me crois maintenant
je m'appelle christine je suis
psychologue beaucoup de gens se demandent ce qui
s'est passé hier soir avec toi et le garçon
si tu me touches
tu brûleras
eric ton ambassade a envoyé des gens
pour te ramener en amérique
monte juste dans la voiture
tu ne peux pas atteindre une ville tu es d'accord
avec moi tu as vu ce qu'il a fait
ici
je l'ai vu de mes propres yeux tu as de la chance
d'être en vie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
parfois j'ai juste ces visions  je vois
bien les choses comme s'il s'agissait d'un monde différent
je peux me promener je peux toucher des choses je
peux sentir des choses je sens le vent je sens
la chaleur
je ne dis pas que c'est une mauvaise personne
je me fiche de ce qu'il est nous avons besoin  pour
le maîtriser,
sortez de là aussi vite que vous le pouvez
[Musique]
je pense qu'il s'est passé quelque chose que personne
comprend tout à fait encore
vous